hello everyone my name is derek
bickhardt i am a research microbiologist
and bioinformatician with the usda
at the dairy forage research center in
madison wisconsin
today i'd like to talk about some
exciting research we've done
using metagenomics to identify
antimicrobial resistance genes
and link them with potential hosts
i'd like to structure my talk into four
different sections
the first i'm going to provide a little
bit of background information on
antibiotic discovery and antibiotic
resistance
then i'll talk a little bit about some
of our recent work on using the cow as a
model organism for this study
and finally how these methods could be
adapted to trace
the presence and transfer of antibiotic
resistant gene alleles
in metagenomes and finally wrap it up
with
some concluding remarks
alexander fleming was credited with
identifying the inhibitory properties of
a mold uh penicillium rubens
on his culture media in 1926
as he famously said that's funny he
noticed an inhibitory ring around
the bacterial colonies on his plate
whenever the mold was present what he
had inadvertently discovered was a
beta-lactam antibiotic
these antibiotics actually inhibit
bacterial cell wall formation
and therefore result in uh bacteriocidal
activity however
despite this discovery it was 15 years
later that
penicillin which was the active
component of
the antibiotic was mass produced
in this case war was the necessity for
mass production
to give you a sense of the scope and
scale i've provided
non-combat deaths on the u.s side for
two major
conflicts the u.s civil war and the
first world war
in parentheses i give the proportion of
all total deaths
suffered by the u.s in relation to the
non-combat deaths
and as you can see if you were a soldier
you were more likely to
die from disease or accidental death
than you were
on by action of the enemy
this was dramatically reduced after the
invention and mass production of
antibiotics
with huge reductions in mortality due to
death
due to disease so much so that uh
several posters at the time were created
to show how
important penicillin was to the war
effort as you can see
as a mark of the time this recovering
soldier is happily smoking a cigarette
in his hospital bed
the production of antibiotics was so
popular that they were actually
prescribed as over-the-counter
medication
in the 50s but that would soon change
with the rise of antibiotic resistance
genes
so as you may have seen from an earlier
slide
the first antibiotics were biotically
produced they were produced by
a fungus but why would a microbe produce
the means to
inhibit or kill other microbes
recent work that's been published traced
the synthesis genes of antibiotics back
and using a evolutionary approach they
determined that antibiotic glycopeptide
antibiotics most likely
first came around 150 to 400 million
years ago
what was interesting though is that the
resistant gene alleles were
said to have arrived shortly thereafter
or simultaneously
this makes perfect evolutionary sense
what you want to do
is clear out your competitors using an
antibiotic
and since many microbes work commensely
and synergistically with each other
many of your friends are most likely to
have resistance to the products you
produce
and this is a winning strategy
first you may have heard me use the term
alleles and i'd like to clarify that
when i use the term alleles when
describing antimicrobial resistance
genes that means the modified
versions of their genes that result in
different outcomes or phenotypes as we
say in genetics
when expressed most antibiotic
antimicrobial resistance genes are
studied in the context of human disease
however they are present in many
different environments
and many different microbial communities
so i ask you to please keep that in mind
additionally bacteria as well are
incredibly diverse
as it turns out many diverse species of
bacteria
have innate immunity to certain
antibiotics
other microbes have to engage in active
countermeasures
in order to destroy or inactivate
certain antibiotics
another evolutionary strategy is if
random mutations actually change the
targets of the antibiotics
that also provides some sort of passive
immunity to them
and finally in many cases
microbes have evolved efflux genes which
constantly
pour poured out these antibiotics so
that
they never build up significant
concentrations within the cell
the development of these alleles in
specific species does not preclude their
transfer to others
there's a well-known phenomenon in
microbial genetics called horizontal
gene
transfer which can result in these
alleles spreading to other species
i only detail a couple of these in this
talk
there are many more the first of which
is transformation
as a natural consequence of their
eventual death
bacteria will lyse and spill out the
contents of the cell
including their dna into the environment
certain bacterial cells are naturally
competent
and will take up this dna and
incorporate it in their genomes
which could result in the transfer of
arg
genes another method is transduction
by which a bacterial virus also known as
a bacteriophage
can accidentally take part of the host's
genome
into itself this is a concept known as
specialized transduction
if that bacteriophage infects another
cell it can transfer the contents of
that host genome
which will then be incorporated in the
recipient and theref
therefore give antibiotic resistance
and finally is conjugation many
bacterial cells have extra chromosomal
dna
such as plasmids sometimes transposons
that can form circular intermediates and
then jump
into the next cell when this occurs
that cell will gain the properties of
that plasmid if the genes are expressed
thereby giving resistance
this makes the entire picture very
complex because horizontal transfer can
result
in many different organisms containing
the same resistance alleles over time
and by using antibiotics you actually
select for these resistant organisms
to proliferate within the community
adding further insult to injury if you
try to detect a single arg allele
in a system using very standard and easy
methods you might detect it but you
don't know the context
you don't know which organism it might
be present within
furthermore by using antibiotics
indiscriminately
you could eliminate many beneficial
microbes that would otherwise take up
the spots that a pathogen might
exhibit this complexity has
resulted in the need for us to use very
complex
methods in order to try to identify all
the potential players
in the community i when i talk about the
term metagenomics what i'm referring to
is the study of microbial genomes
derived from an environment surface or
tissue
but more specifically and for many of
the technically oriented i'm talking
mostly about using dna
sequencing to try to identify the
components
of these species and communities
to give an example this is a phylogram
from
a recent work on the rumen from one of
our collaborators just to show the
diversity of those different species we
try to identify
in metagenomics approaches
furthermore we can actually take
advantage of new technologies
that result in longer reads and better
information
on these communities to try to identify
new biological facets to them
so in the context of our metagenomics
experiments
what we're basically looking for is to
identify
the presence and prevalence of arg
alleles in the community
we'd also like to see whether or not
there are any bad actors that could
actually
take up these arg alleles and to try to
catch them red handed
in the process and finally
we would like to see also which
beneficial microbes would be
impacted by antibiotic treatment do they
harbor natural resistance
these are some questions that we can
answer with metagenomics
and in that context i'd like to present
some work that we've done
using the cattle rumen as a model for
this system
many people might not look at the cow as
a good model for this
but i'd like to point out that many of
the improvements in
dairy cattle production we've made are
incredibly important and really
marvelous to behold
the cattle production in the u.s is a
huge agricultural success story
and don't just take my word for it i'd
like to present some data
in this graph i'm showing on the
leftmost y-axis
the number of dairy cattle in the u.s as
a function of time on the x
on the right-most y-axis i actually
showed the
average milk per cow in kilograms
for thousands since the 1980s we've
actually reduced
the total number of dairy cows in the
u.s herd by
20 at the same time we've doubled
the average milk production per cow
resulting in a net increase in milk
despite the lower number of cows
and even though i began as a dairy
cattle geneticist
at the usda i do have to acknowledge
that
most a lot of this is due to many
different advances in different
fields this is truly an
interdisciplinary effort
the rumen itself is an interesting organ
it develops from the esophagus of the
animal
and turns into a large pouch that
is subject to muscular activity to move
food around and it's colonized by a huge
diversity of microbes
the cow itself is completely reliant on
the microbes for digestion of
complex plant material if it did not
have the microbes the cow would starve
the bacteria provide energy and
nutrients to the cow through
fermentation end products
and after they die they are passed
through the intestine to provide
protein to the animal
we actually use very limited antibiotics
in dairy cattle in order to improve
production one of which is term benensin
it's an ionophore that is effective
against gram positives
by feeding the cow menensin we actually
reduce some of the gram positives
and change the fermentation end products
to improve milk production
menensin is not suitable for use in
humans it has high toxicity
so the fda approved this for use in
dairy cattle
herds
the rumen microbiome is very diverse and
actually includes
organisms from all three major super
kingdoms
the first of which are the bacteria
which represent half of the biomass of
the rumen
and are the major fermenters of plant
material
the second are archaea and these are the
guys that produce the greenhouse gases
that everyone has heard about
and finally are the eukaryotes they're
both fungi
and protists that are present in the
rumen of the cows
the fungi do some cellular digestion of
plant material
and the protists consume bacteria
to produce provide additional fatty
acids to the cow
but i guess the question is why use the
cow as a model for this
there are several reasons the first is
that the cow is incredibly important to
us food safety and is important to human
health
it can harbor some pathogens that
eventually progress down the food chain
so it's a vital importance for us to
study cattle
the second is since we do provide
antibiotics for both convalescent
therapy
and to improve production the cow is
also a great model system for microbial
dynamics
and as to the question why now we
actually have made
several huge improvements in different
technologies that we can use to
study metagenomes mostly in the terms of
dna sequencing technologies
in order to characterize this we
selected one
cow cannulated cow and
tried to use as many different
technologies as possible
to identify differences in the community
and
identify other biological facets that
are going on
so we took a cannula sample directly
from the rumen of the cow
and extracted the dna and sequenced it
using
a short read technology that has been
around for
a fair bit of time and a new dna
sequencing technology that involves
longer
breeds subsequently we also
identified conformational signal using
high c
a method that can actually identify the
3d structure of dna
within the cell
when you first start out with this
project one thing i'd like to impress
upon you is the scale
when you're working with dna it's
literally like trying to solve a million
jigsaw puzzles all at once but whereas
everyone tells you to look at the box
to identify the picture and work from
there we have no idea what
the sequence looks like in order to get
around this
many clever people have developed
algorithms that allow us to piece
together all these
puzzle pieces together and identify the
optimal confirmation
these are called genome assembly
algorithms
and what it can result in is turning a
very
very fragmented picture such as the one
on the left
into something that's much more sharp
and provides additional focus on
new features to give you a sense in this
community
using the shorter read technology we
eventually assembled
two million pieces or contigs as we call
them and the long read assembly
assembled 77 000 pieces so even though
we've reduced the complexity there's
still quite a lot to dig
through
and this is just to show you briefly
that the newer technologies do result in
improvements
uh on the x-axis i show you the average
size
of the density of sizes of these
different pieces of dna
and on the y-axis i have sec segregated
them by the bacterial taxonomic clade
with the bacteria archaea and eukaryotes
you can see in all cases that the longer
reeds in orange produced
much uh longer contigs as well as a
function
what's interesting too is that they also
assembled longer viral contigs
and we wanted to take a look at this in
more detail
so viruses comprise a series of mobile
dna
and their great interest in the rumen
we've actually identified that viral
activity may
change the metabolic activity of
microbes in the rumen
driving sulfur metabolism further
so what i wanted to do is using the
information we already had at hand
i wanted to take the longer reads
overlap them with the viruses to
identify
the potential hosts for the viruses and
also use that conformational signal
i talked about before to also try to
find
viral hosts when i ran the analysis
i was disappointed i had assumed that
both methods
would find the same thing and confirm
the results
as it turns out there was only 10
percent overlap between these two
methods
in this case it's very easy to give up
but i was actually
quite fortunate to have great
collaborators on this project
uh specifically max press of phase
genomics
max told me when i was about ready to
give up he said no no no there's
something to look at here
just continue and just to stop him from
pestering me i thought i'll
give this another look
at the same time i was thinking that not
all bacteriophage are alike
they have different cycles uh that
different life cycles that result in
different behavior within the cell
there are two different classes uh among
the popular ones one is a lytic phage
which actually exists outside of the
cell in a sort of plasmid-like state
and replicates itself and the other is a
lysogenic phage
which will enter the cell and integrate
with the genome and hitch a ride
in the genome of the bacterium
i thought okay if max is correct
only the conformational signal would be
able to detect the phage dna
i would never have long reads that would
span the phage dna
and host dna however
the long reads would be the only method
to identify the lysogenic phage
in this scenario because we could
identify where they're integrating into
the genome
so i created a network plot in order to
visualize this
and just to briefly go over this each
one of the pieces
of sequence the contigs are a circle
or a hexagon with the viruses being the
colored hexagons
classified by their viral family the
myoviridae the sephora viridae and the
poto viridae
the bacterial hosts are the
teal circles the connections between
them are color coded
the light blue is detected by long reads
the dark blue is detected by the
conformational high c
and the red is where it's detected by
both
and you can see from just looking at all
the the long read links
that there are some patterns that emerge
but what was really transformational was
when i took a look at the whole picture
and saw it very clearly the myoviridae
were primarily being detected in their
associations by the high sea links
and this actually makes sense it turns
out the myoviruday
many of the members of that family are
lytic phages
so they can only be detected by the high
c whereas the other viral classes
were a mix of lysogenic and lytic phage
as well
we derived many different biological
features from this
including a confirmation of the sulfur
metabolism that
viruses drive in the rumen as well as
several different strains of bacteria
that they can infect
as well as many different species that
could be infected by
the same viral strain
this was great and showed a dynamic that
we
otherwise would have missed
so how do we take this method and adapt
it to identifying
arg resistance alleles
we know that the bacteriophage are
highly mobile and
since arg alleles tend to be
tend to exist on mobile dna as well we
could potentially use these methods to
identify them
in different hosts as well
first we wanted to take a look and see
what arg alleles were in our sample
and see whether or not our sequencing
technologies can improve
their detection so working with
uh another lab at the usda run by brad
haley
we classified the different antibiotic
resistance alleles
and you can see on the left uh
underneath each of the plots
we have different classes of antibiotics
and
the subset of the plot on the left is
for the short read
data and the one on the right is for the
long read
it should be very clear at first the the
short read
assembly had far fewer detected alleles
whereas the long read assembly had
anywhere from a two
to a 16-fold more increase in arg allele
detections
with the exception of amino glycoside
alleles
what was interesting too was the
magnitude of the tetracycline alleles
this had not been previously reported in
the rumen
given the number of alleles i couldn't
use a network plot for this analysis so
i used the next best visualization
called a heat map
on the each row is a bacterial genome
and each column represents an arg allele
and the intensity scales from black
where there are no
high c links or long read links
to dark red where the highest links are
present
you can see from some of the patterns
that there is a lot of sharing of art
alleles within
distinct groups in fact when i took a
look at the
bacterial genomes that were present they
classified into different genera
including the privetella
the clustering alleys and the
bacteroidetes
however there's a big ocean right here
where
there isn't really a clear pattern
despite clustering
and it looks as if there's a lot more
promiscuous transfer between different
hosts
with several bacterial gene
genomes being highly susceptible to art
allele transfer
so with these technologies we can track
mobile dna in complex communities
a lot better some other groups have
started using these methods
or similar methods including a group at
cornell that actually found that hard
allele transfer
in neutrogen neutropenic patients was
far
larger than those found in healthy
patients
while i'm hopeful that this technology
can be adapted
and used in clinical settings there's
still quite a long ways to go
in order to increase the turnaround and
increase the throughput
but so far we're making great strides
towards using this on a regular basis
so to summarize the talk i hope that you
step away from this
by realizing that antibiotic resistance
and antibiotic production are two
naturally occurring events
that occur every day and have evolved
simultaneously
as an evolutionary strategy for microbes
that means that our alleles tend to be
quite ubiquitous in the environment
and we must always consider sources
for these arg alleles whenever we use
intervention therapies
using the cal rumen we actually
demonstrated that
new dna sequencing technologies can
identify
argh allele transfer and determine the
hosts for these args
and we hope that these methods can be
adapted and used
in other settings such as clinical
settings as well
i'd like to acknowledge many different
people there are far too many to list
but among these are many of my
colleagues at the usda
especially tim smith uh
kevin panky bussey and kurt van tassel
i'd also like to thank uh mick watson of
the roslin institute
for his advice and guidance on the
assemblies
uh adam philippi and serge korin at the
nih
i'd also like to thank our industry
partners at pac bio and phase genomics
and our academic partners among these
were garrett suen at uw madison
much of this work has been funded by
appropriated funds from the usda
also from usda nifa grant funds as well
and since i've used some some trade
names in this
talk i'd like to state that the usda
does not endorse products or services
and that
trade names are used for informational
purposes thank you very much for your
attention and time